[Music]
foreign
oh my god i just saw scott santa had to
jump over to the rick sarah podcast
is he on right now oh my god i love him
that dude
he's hilarious if you don't know he does
a lot of [ __ ] with uh dan bell
and uh they do another dirty room
together and [ __ ] like that rick
sarah is [ __ ]
shameless and disgusting he'll he will
do
literally anything dan's always just
kind of like hey
eat the hotel soap how does that taste
hey stick your hand in that drain where
there's like [ __ ]
strangers pubic hair and semen stains
and boogers and [ __ ] and rick sarah's
just totally he'll totally do it
yep it's the craziest [ __ ] i've ever
seen i haven't i've never watched like
his because i guess he has his own
channel
but um because i've only seen him like
on the damn bell stuff but holy crap
that dude just like and i i really like
the ones too where they've done another
dirty room where
they've just gotten completely [ __ ]
shit-faced kind of like we do on this
show
um it's just the [ __ ] that he does it's
just like
[ __ ] oh my god you guys if you
haven't seen like another dirty room
it's nasty like don't watch it while
you're [ __ ] eating or anything but
what are you doing i'm going to show
them michonne khan
and it con suns did he say you could do
that
yep down in mexico there they are that's
car
this is
they're like yeah we're all like
gangster and [ __ ] like that yeah we're
back on finally
i'm here i don't know i i'm just really
kind of
sick of this [ __ ] dropping i'm ready to
like fling this [ __ ] laptop
and just like order another one like i
said i have two other computers but
there's so much [ __ ] on them and they're
old too so it's like i don't know
all right so you want to get back to
where we're talking about go ahead and
do what you want to do yeah
oh scott says it's just him drinking
with his wife and talking about movies
oh
all right well yeah i might have to like
watch that then because i've only seen
him on
another dirty room on another dirty room
it's like you know with dan's shows
where they go and like
investigate abandoned places and whatnot
and he's
like [ __ ] funny on that [ __ ] just
because like i said because he'll
[ __ ] do anything
and he's kind of an idiot but not i
don't mean that in a bad way but he's
just kind of like
i don't know he's just like [ __ ]
shameless and kind of gross
uh and it's really funny so all right so
at this stage like i said they get
everybody out
but at this point uh then the following
morning
they found all the bombs in there and
obviously you find anything that looks
like bomb you can't let
anybody in there so there were still a
lot of dead bodies like in the school at
this point which must have been
[ __ ] horrible but at this point they
were able
they were able to establish the uh you
know final death
toll sadly uh 12 students and one
teacher
uh if you want to be technical it was 14
students including the two douche bags
who did this [ __ ]
uh 20 students and one teacher were also
injured
i will say too there were some um
things that happened in the aftermath uh
some students some
parents of uh students that died like
killed themselves later on like after
the thing so there were like
you know deaths that happened as a
result of this afterward
uh so yeah so it took a long time for
all of this [ __ ] to get sorted out sadly
um now
so a few days after the shooting this is
kind of interesting too
so this one carpenter named greg zannis
now he puts up this was april 30th so it
was like 10 days after the shooting so
he puts up
15 uh wooden crosses they were like six
feet tall
and they were as memorials to honor all
those who died but 15 of them
which means that he was including dylan
and eric in the toll and the total
this didn't sit so well with some of the
parents and i can't say i blame them
uh so one of the victim's dads uh
the dad of daniel rorbow kept going in
there and cutting them down
and like i said can't blame them same
thing happened later on when they tried
they planted a bunch of like memorial
trees and they planted 15 of them and
somebody kept cutting down two of them
because
they thought that the shooters should
not be memorialized and like i said you
can't really blame them because that was
their [ __ ] kids that got killed so
you know
and uh i i went into earlier that whole
like christian martyrdom thing that
weird [ __ ] [ __ ] that happened after
with uh cassie bernal
and how her i guess it was her mom that
like wrote the book and it was like she
said yes and this whole myth like sprung
up about oh she said yes she believed in
god and then
she got shot in the face and that's not
what happened
um even after they discovered that
that's what happened they pretty much
ran with it anyway because that was
already the story that had been
established and that was kind of the
story that everyone kind of hitched
their wagon to
um and that was kind of bringing in
you know somebody mentioned grief porn
earlier
it's you know it's sad but it works uh
and uh
so that's it's not entirely what
happened so i'm just saying
that but they kind of like uh [ __ ]
milked that for all it was worth
so sadly now uh
let's kind of get into the [ __ ] that
happened in the aftermath because
this being the first major school
shooting
and uh up until then the worst one that
had ever happened
there were a lot of [ __ ] people
speculating on why
this happened why you know what their
motives were and
everything as we mentioned earlier from
[ __ ]
you know doom to [ __ ] marilyn manson
to
oh they were nazis or oh there was this
that and the other
everything was kind of examined in light
of this
and i do kind of feel like this
was a secondary not as bad
but a secondary satanic panic it was it
it just it went into the same exact
narrative that satanic panic did
satanic panic was the well the weird
thing though about the satanic panic was
that was one that was like a lot longer
uh lasting and it didn't really i don't
think the satanic panic
necessarily sprung from a single
cataclysmic event like this did
um it was just kind of like this weird
long-term like malaise where it's like
oh well there's this it was like this
urban legend about all these like
satanic cults that were like killing
babies
and all these daycare center workers are
flushing kids down toilets and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
we should do another show about that
like i said i want to talk more about
the mcmartin preschool case and
everything
but uh we'll do a revisit because like i
said we did satanic panic but it was way
back on
episode two and that was like when we
didn't really know what we were doing
so i really kind of want to do like more
of a deep dive on it and it was probably
like
only an hour long but so but i feel like
this
it kind of like it went into the same
kind of narratives because as soon as it
happened every single tiny little thing
the fact that they wore black dusters
suddenly they were a member of the
trenchcoat mafia suddenly
they you know they liked km fdm so
therefore
uh you know they were all they were into
all this like dark [ __ ] and they were
satanists and
you know therefore they played doom so
they wanted to like shoot so that was to
blame and it just seems like that
everybody was looking for something
easy to point to
as to why these two kids had pulled this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
because as i said in a lot of ways they
seemed completely normal their parents
had no idea what was going on
like i said they didn't come from broken
homes they didn't come i mean they both
had
um you know there's a lot of dudes like
this no matter that's what i mean and
that's
that's what i think really bothers
people and this is something that i
bring up a lot on this show i feel like
because
i feel like you know it's not humans
fault this is just how our brains work
um human brains are really not equipped
to deal with
the with the complexity of the world so
it's always kind of like they're looking
for
easy solutions shortcut solutions
they're looking for something that's
very easy
so when something like this happens that
is
in their minds inexplicable they're
looking for
one thing that'll be that'll unlock it
like i said it was it's kind of like
what we were talking about earlier like
with the incels they're looking for that
one magical
thing that you can say to a woman that
will get her to drop your
dropper panties you know what i mean so
everybody's looking for that one easy
thing
there is no one easy thing there just
isn't it's like i know it sucks
but i know your brain wants it to be
like that
but nothing is like that and so i do
kind of feel like in the wake of a
tragedy like this where so many innocent
lives
were snuffed out everybody's looking for
an explanation and it's really easy
to blame you know a video game where you
just go around
killing people it's very easy to blame
music that's saying yeah kill them all
or whatever it's very easy to blame that
but that's
never ever the thing that causes
somebody to do things like this because
as i said millions of people played doom
millions of people listened to km fdm
and marilyn manson and it's like you
know
a tiny .0001 percent
of people that enjoy that kind of media
ever do anything like this
most people are just very normal i watch
horror movies i've watched horror movies
since i was six or seven years old
you know i'm into like goth music i'm
into all that kind of stuff i would
never do this in a million [ __ ] years
ever and most people wouldn't so
i do kind of feel like the problem here
was
i think that the music they listened to
and stuff like that maybe they felt that
that
spoke to them in a way because maybe
they felt isolated but i do kind of feel
like that they had mental problems
before all this [ __ ] [ __ ] happened
well that that [ __ ] song that they're
talking that song that they're talking
about probably is
is the kmft kmfdm song i think it's
i think it's off that album or was some
called godlike yeah god like
yeah they they mentioned that
specifically yeah
and that was a [ __ ] real driving
upbeat [ __ ]
industrial [ __ ] dance
track at the time so yeah
you know what i mean [ __ ] but that
didn't make them do it but i could see
that they could that they would like
that
that was a good song yeah like i said i
think maybe and this is not to imply
that everybody that's into dark [ __ ] and
stuff because obviously i'd be implying
that about myself
but that's not to say that everybody
that likes
dark music or you know movies or
whatever
that they have a problem or something
like that but i can see why people who
already have problems
might be drawn to something like that
because these two well eric harris in
particular
dylan klebold to a maybe to a lesser
extent i feel like dylan
he had a lot of the same issues that
eric had but i do kind of feel like
dylan's [ __ ] was more he was more
uh it was more turned inward he seemed
more suicidal
self-loathing um whereas eric harris was
much
more like a classic psychopath in the
sense that he was glib he enjoyed
um being able to manipulate people being
able to
um make people think about him what they
wanted him
to think about you know what he what he
wanted to uh you know put across to them
so i do kind of feel like he had a lot
of that going on he just wanted to kill
her but he was just angry he hated
everybody he thought he was better than
everybody
um and i think the fact that i think
dylan looked up to him maybe a little
bit
um and like i said i'm not that i'm not
excusing dylan because he didn't have to
do this [ __ ] obviously
but i do feel like there was a really
really bad synergy
going on there and dylan was a little
bit
i think he was a little bit more easy to
manipulate
and maybe he thought eric was cool like
in all the [ __ ]
psycho [ __ ] he was doing and he wanted
to get
in on that you know what i mean a little
bit maybe i kind of feel like that was
maybe the dynamic that was happening
but as i said i can see why people that
feel that way because
you know i felt that way a lot of my
friends felt that way
you know growing up you're a little bit
you're different you know i grew up in
like a
kind of a shitty redneck town and you
know people picked on you if you look
different
and so i can see how it would be really
attractive
to just kind of blame everyone else and
just be like yeah i'm just going to kill
all you [ __ ] because you're all
so mean to me
but you know i get it but you can't do
that
you know what i mean you just you can't
do that
but i do kind of feel like they got to a
point because eric harris had this
self-aggrandizing this grandiosity
this god-like complex that he had
he kind of felt like he could do that
like he was justified
and i think that's a really dangerous
mindset for
a teenage boy to have particularly and
especially one that had a friend that
was
maybe a little bit more suggestible and
was already suicidal to start with
who was completely happy to go along
with these fantasies
because what they were is power
fantasies um
these were two guys who even though
as i said they had a lot of advantages
in life
as i said they were not poor um they
were not
ostracized to any great degree
um you know perhaps they weren't as
popular as they would have liked to be
but they obviously they weren't [ __ ]
scorned by everyone they had friends
they you know they did things they had
activities that they did and whatnot
um so i do kind of feel like this
victimization complex that they had
um it just kind of fed on itself and
they fed on each other
so i kind of feel like they were just
constantly talking about how yeah man
it's like
you know what the cool people don't like
us and we don't go to the best parties
and all the hot girls don't like us and
you know everything sucks we're gonna
burn the whole world you know what i
mean
and i did know some people like that
like when i was a teenager
so i do understand that mindset but
it's just i don't know man it's and and
like i said it's really hard to
it's hard to um you know
imagine out of everybody that feels like
that when you're a teenager because it
is a lot of people
like who is actually gonna cross the
line and do this kind of [ __ ]
but i think the thing about it is that
all of these stupid [ __ ] motives
that they came up with it's like oh it's
marilyn manson's fault
even though like i said they weren't
even really that into marilyn manson
i mean [ __ ] man marilyn manson he got
[ __ ] on so much
for this i mean he had to cancel some
tours
uh you know they he was just like had to
go
all over the talk show circuit and like
everybody [ __ ] asked him about he's
like look like these
these kids like they didn't even they
weren't really that into my music and
it's like i don't know how i got roped
into this [ __ ] just because i happen to
be the
poster boy for like weird [ __ ]
music at the time so you know
so all that kind of happened and then
all the [ __ ] they were blaming the fact
that they did that
as you said in the 90 in the late 90s
it's almost kind of like everything was
sort of getting to be okay
if you looked like a weirdo or whatever
like if you were into goth
but after this happened it was almost
kind of like satanic panic all over
again like maybe to a little bit of a
lesser degree
but it's like because everybody had kind
of started to
kind of know what it was because it had
kind of gone you know you had the craft
and you had like people knew what it was
then
but after columbine happened holy [ __ ]
man people were throwing bottles at you
out of cars like you said
um you know it got shitty you know the
show you did yeah
yeah you're walking down the street and
[ __ ] people throwing caught bottles
out
of the [ __ ] car window at you the
[ __ ] was all that about
yeah [ __ ] marilyn manson you know
what yeah people would say [ __ ] like
that to you and like people would even
like
if you're maryland if you were if you
were wearing a coat because it's cold
people feel like
columbine like people like do that to
you absolutely
and like i said those two dudes were
like not even i feel like they weren't
even really into that [ __ ]
i mean not really not the way people we
knew were
so i don't know so so it's really and
it's dangerous too because i feel like
all these misconceptions that sprung up
around this
shooting maybe
kind of fed into some of the school
shootings that happened later because
like i said the shitty thing is that
there were a [ __ ]
ton of copycat crimes and a lot of the
school shootings that happened after
this
um i believe it was easily at least a
dozen of them
uh you know the perpetrators of those
school shootings directly referenced
the columbine shooting as their
inspiration and
specifically said it's a you know oh
we're getting back at you know we're the
dispossessed and we're getting back at
the man or we're getting back at the
jocks or
we're getting back at whatever and it's
just kind of like so
so it's bad that the the message of it
became so muddled that it's like oh
it was almost like justified because
these two have been picked on
so they just took revenge and i feel
like that narrative really
that ended up being really harmful in
the end because i feel like some
people that maybe were disaffected and
had some
mental problems took that as a rallying
cry
and uh then later on we're just kind of
like hey i'm going to do that same [ __ ]
too they're my heroes man
and they're still even to this day as
far as i know i was kind of too scared
to look but
i saw some like a year or two back um
you know there's some
reddit [ __ ] and somebody said there was
like fan like all kind of like
fanfic about them too but there's all
kind of
you know subreddits that are idolizing
these two
dudes and like their ideas or their
benefits
or whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it
well it was just kind of like
you know that [ __ ] douche we were
talking about earlier elliot roger
there's whole subreddits devoted to him
as well
uh to his philosophy i guess you would
call it
um dudes agreeing with it and saying
yeah man this is what we need to do
you know so not great that that's really
not
a great thing to be idolizing but some
people do idolize this
mindset and this kind of [ __ ] to do
which is kind of [ __ ] scary
you know yeah i'm just saying yeah i'm
not
i'm not sure i'm not sure how serious
they are about that i think there's some
[ __ ] kind of like fantasy role play
behind a lot of that larping that you
like rob farrell or that you like the
[ __ ] columbine shooters
i think yeah some of that might be edgy
[ __ ]
[ __ ] in the moment of some [ __ ] 14
year old [ __ ] boy
who doesn't know the [ __ ] he's talking
about you know yeah because if you're 14
here i'm telling you right now you know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about i
mean i didn't know what the [ __ ] i was
talking about was for nobody does no
thanks
nobody does no offense you know what the
[ __ ] i didn't he didn't nobody
nobody when you're 14. you don't know
anything you feel like you do
i get it i remember um i get it
yeah but you don't you think fast but
there's nothing in your [ __ ] brain
no experience yeah no
it's funny because it's it it seems like
it happens every generation
like you're [ __ ] all the teenagers
like man we know everything and like the
older people they don't know anything
and then like the old people you get old
and then you're just kind of like man
[ __ ] man i can't believe they don't know
anything
but it's like i get it i i remember
being a teenager and feeling like
you know everything and like oh these
old people are so stupid when you're
young you're not questioning the sources
of your information
you learn something and then you accept
it you build on that and you build and
you build and you build
you might be building on an erroneous
foundation
uh or you might be you might maybe you
were given information that was
temporary information
it's information that you tell an
eight-year-old or a nine-year-old or a
ten-year-old
and now you're 14 you're still you still
building a little bit
on the foundation of something that
somebody told you when you were 10
and it was just some [ __ ] well yeah
it was probably something your other
10 year old friend told you or some [ __ ]
that your parents told you
just to keep you out of trouble asking
questions yeah yeah or some [ __ ] like
that you know what i mean or something
that you just read
and you didn't really [ __ ] look into
the source
of where you were you didn't really
understand yeah
and then you don't understand the
[ __ ] the games that
that adults play uh and the games that
adults play with each other [ __ ] mind
games
kids are not very sophisticated from
they're not really all that
sophisticated enough for
they can't detect deception as well as
an adult
can and there's a lot of [ __ ] adults
that can't detect deception
especially if it's from a you know like
a like a trusted authority figure
you know okay yeah well a lot of the
things
a lot of the theoretical [ __ ] about that
at least from what i read a few years
back
was that believing pretty much
everything from an you know an authority
figure an adult when you're a kid
is actually a survival strategy
obviously
um you know well as i said for obvious
reasons because when you're a little kid
and you're kind of vulnerable and
everything the [ __ ] that the adults are
telling you around you
to keep you safe should in theory um
be something that would keep you from
getting eaten by lions or whatever
but the problem is that uh
nowadays like adults can just like now
we're pro mostly all
safe from being eaten by lions so now
adults can just tell you [ __ ] and so
sometimes
people retain that mindset into
adulthood
which seems um problematic
yeah well they have easy lives
so people a lot of people have easier
easy lives
they just do what they're told they
collect their paycheck they spend their
money
they pay bills they do [ __ ] like that
but that's that's hard yeah i've been
there done it
it's just that's not that's not really
as stressful not really
i want to say stressful that's not what
you evolved to do what you really
evolved to do is to walk around
catch [ __ ] [ __ ] kill it cook it you
eat it
and share it and get somebody pregnant
and then make little copies of
yourselves
and make a little [ __ ] thatched roof
and then [ __ ] move on to the next
place you catch some fish
and then eat some that it's it's it and
it's all just in a small
family group that's really what you're
built for you're not really built for
these [ __ ] big old civilizations
with [ __ ] whole industries designed
just on [ __ ] taking money or
controlling your mind well to be honest
with you
um in a lot of ways like people like oh
you know
everything's shitty nowadays but
considering what we evolved to do i
think we're doing
okay like yeah a lot of people are
stressed out and neurotic and we can't
we're not really equipped to deal with
it but considering that
i think we're doing better than i would
have expected let's put it that way look
there's [ __ ]
one thing i would kill a million of you
[ __ ] for one goddamn thing
let's keep my goddamn ac on
i just need where did that come from
about air conditioning that's what
civilization is about for me
right now i don't need any of that other
[ __ ] just that air conditioning
well um and indoor plumbing is nice too
that's all right
but if you gave me the choice
between indoor plumbing and air
conditioning and i said i need the air
conditioning well in florida
you're out there like that [ __ ]
taking a dump outside
yeah that's really funny you can't
replace air conditioning
like i said in in florida out here i'm
telling you right now you live in
florida
i don't understand how people lived here
before air conditioning was invented i
realized
well they didn't they didn't that's true
largely
they largely i mean some people did but
yeah on the coast
where it was breezy all the time but
yeah yeah talking a few thousand people
really they didn't really live here
yeah it was a [ __ ] swamp that's why
everybody's moving here now
because it's not overgrown and it's
civilization
now but it's a fragile civilization
based upon [ __ ] air conditioning if
if the air conditioning was not here
none of this [ __ ] would be here no it
wouldn't
it would go back to [ __ ]
pre-air-conditioning [ __ ] population
which is low
yeah everybody would get the [ __ ] out of
here get the [ __ ] i'm gonna get the [ __ ]
out of here
i don't live in this [ __ ] hole without
[ __ ] air conditioning [ __ ] that
[ __ ] man i've had you know we've had
several hurricanes where
i had one back in 2004 2005
knocked my power up for eight days yeah
um
and also we had one our power was out
for two or three days
and it's just like yeah no thank you no
thank you that's why you get these
politicians down from [ __ ] san
francisco where tila lives
saying well we're gonna have to [ __ ]
get rid of air conditioning
to [ __ ] reduce our carbon footprint
that's a real quick way to get your [ __ ]
[ __ ] shot up
i mean i like look you would kill
everyone doesn't need air conditioning
it depends on where you live in florida
yeah you do yes florida would raise a
nuclear
[ __ ] combat against california over
air conditioning
because it would kill half the
population or like i said you'd have to
move
you'd have to move right i could not
live here without air conditioning you
couldn't
most people couldn't no it's unlivable
air conditioning it's unlivable it's
[ __ ] 100 degrees and a hundred and a
hundred percent
well and not just half the year and it's
not just discomfort
it's there's other things to there's
things like the mold and mold
yeah mold all the houses would fall over
mold would grow in your [ __ ] well [ __ ]
mold grows in my shower yeah and we have
air conditioning i have to spray the
[ __ ] with bleach
once a week yeah tina goes florida that
it without ac and it days exactly
it would go zombie no one would live
here it'd be like a walking dead
and i would not blame them i would not
live here and i was born here
yeah you'd think i'd be used to it but
i'm not i hate it well you know they run
their mouths they don't know what
they're [ __ ] talking about well we
don't want you to
reduce the carbon footprint we're gonna
have to get rid of air conditioning and
this and that and [ __ ] of course
but is florida's to have to pay its fair
share of taxes to our federal government
where those share fair share of taxes
will instantly evaporate
when about 75 of florida's population
runs from florida
into cooler [ __ ] regions
yeah so that'd be the end of your [ __ ]
because then they'd flood other markets
just that's just not how the world works
so the world is very complicated
and it's too complicated for politicians
that's why we have to get rid of them
we just need to be run by brainiac well
they're called brain well the thing
about it though is that
yeah it's too complicated too
complicated for them it's too
complicated for anybody
yeah um that's why it just needs to be a
network
not in a top-down system
how did we get off on air today why did
you start talking about air conditioning
hormones man hormones are a [ __ ] hell
of a drug i'm [ __ ] hot
look what he's doing i'm hot and [ __ ]
sweating oh is that i'm sweating bacon
grease
i forgot i forgot that's why he just
randomly started talking about air
conditioning
it's because he's having hot flashes
you're right he has menopause
yeah no this is [ __ ] puberty part two
puberty two elections i have a [ __ ] i
have a [ __ ] i have the [ __ ]
hormone [ __ ]
[ __ ] blood con i'm probably running a
[ __ ] like
what they call a [ __ ] private 1100
nanograms right now
per decade that doesn't mean anything to
anybody [ __ ] i got like the [ __ ]
i'm like
i got the [ __ ] testosterone of a high
end [ __ ]
17 year old right now probably
it's what it feels like yeah
it's a 200 milligram dose [ __ ] per
week can you guys like
can you guys just like imagine for a
second what a weird situation this is
for
it's almost like pond far from [ __ ]
from [ __ ]
star trek sort of it's [ __ ] well yeah
it's not
but no it's not as fun as it's not not
as fun as that but
it's considerably less fun yeah
if i told you i've told you guys right
because i i don't know if i ever posted
the video of this
but before we got pookie fixed when she
was real little
um she was only [ __ ] man she was
probably
less than six months old and we uh made
an appointment to get her fixed
like you do because you know we're
responsible um
but about a week or two before her
appointment
she went into heat like for for the
first time
that poor little baby she was still like
a baby
at this point she had no idea what was
going on but i had to film it because i
felt bad but it was also super super
funny
because she was just she was in the
kitchen and she was like on the kitchen
floor
and she was like sticking her tiny
little butt with her little stumpy tail
and she's just sticking it up in there
and she's sticking her butt like at
everybody and she's just like making the
funniest [ __ ]
what's that noise she was making she was
just kind of like
she was she sounded like she was making
this horrible little noise and i was
just like oh my god i felt so bad
but i still filmed it because it was
funny malachi washington says i'm 17.
i didn't even think i'd make it to 17.
okay
see well everybody feels like that um i
remember
when i was in sixth grade
which how old was i was what year would
that have been 83 84
84. it would have been 1984. and i
remember
we were talking about um
i don't know we were talking about like
a sci-fi book we were reading or
something like that
people were talking about like the year
2000 and i remember
very vividly thinking that i was 12
years old
thinking about the year 2000 and i was
like oh my god
i'll be 28 that's so old
i remember thinking that well when when
you're 12 years old like 28 seems like
super super old
and it was like the year 2000 it seemed
like a [ __ ] lifetime away right
and it's like now i'm 20 years older
than that it's like so weird to like
look back on that
what's funny is how fast 10 years goes
by now
well you know a lot of people have you
know mentioned that that the older you
get like the faster time seems to go
but i don't know it's weird because
i have a very strange relationship to
time i'm not really
i don't know i i get to a point where
after a certain point like my past is
not really
i don't know i just feel like that's not
really me anymore after that head injury
i don't really feel time well yeah i
know you don't
yeah i have to get look we have a clock
in the room
it's right there but i still have to get
up out of my office and walk
all the way across the house and tell
him what time it is yeah so
he knows what time it's my [ __ ]
superpower though he can't just like
just look at the clock i have to get up
and go over there and tell him what to
do
i'll just be doing other [ __ ]
this is my superpower though i have like
unlimited endurance because i don't feel
any [ __ ]
passage of time you know i just down
except you kind of do because i'm tired
yeah
you get one you get tired and two you
know you'd be like oh this thing that
happened
like a year ago i'm like dude that was
like nine years ago yeah one time
i don't feel the passage of the time i
don't know if that's a superpower
it doesn't matter i die anyway you know
what i mean you died anyway
it doesn't matter if you feel the
passage of the time or not
it's really weird i don't know if other
people that
you know get to this age because like i
said i always thought i would
die before this age i mean we grew up in
the 80s
um so we just thought that the world
would be
subsumed in a nuclear holocaust by this
by this point
um well i'm just saying in general like
a lot of people thought that
um i did not think that i would live to
this age i really did not
i thought it would be like blade runner
you'd have flying cars
and gigantic cities everywhere see i
always thought flying cars were a bad
idea yeah that's what i thought it would
be but i don't think
i still don't think flying cars would be
good i thought mississippi would be
cities like
out of [ __ ] blade runner really yeah
by this time yeah oh yeah big c big
[ __ ] skyscrapers
but no skyscrapers are not in the future
actually that's a very inefficient
structure you don't need it
not in the american situation people can
spread out
you don't need to [ __ ] stack people
one on top of the other that you can't
make any money with this guy with the
skyscraper anymore
because what they were for is for office
buildings is where it started so you
don't need office building people work
from home
that has changed the game and it hasn't
really sunk in yet
although i did hear some [ __ ] some
new yorkers
realize you know what we don't really
have to go back
yeah they're like yeah we can work from
home now we can just we can we can live
anywhere now
yeah it totally changes the game well
that means that [ __ ]
commercial real estate values will
[ __ ] plummet and well guess what
the banks are [ __ ] heavily invested
in [ __ ] commercial real estate
so what happens when the value of
commercial real estate [ __ ] plummets
what are the banks going to do to try to
[ __ ] recoup their losses
these banks are going to get dangerous
something's going to be done about that
banks are gonna have to be nationalized
or something
and of course they will never allow that
because the banks own the comp
own the government because the
government's
not independent it's owned by these
oligarchs
which people will eventually figure out
figure out that most of these elections
don't matter
because the oligarchs on both sides
doesn't matter who wins and here's the
thing i mean
at the i thought something was weird at
around 40
45 i was concerned i was very because
now i [ __ ] know i
[ __ ] know it's a good guy you need to
listen to from back in the 30s his name
was general [ __ ] smidgley butler
is an audiobook of his up on youtube
it's called war is a racket
and he crushed about a dozen
central american banana republic
countries in the name of [ __ ]
new york bankers he's the ones that
actually made
south and central america the [ __ ] up
place it is today
he was the one that was ordered to do it
all and he tells it all in that damn
book
war is a racket general smedley butler
and he did it under the command of a
bunch of guys living up in new york city
and then they hired him later on they
wanted to hire him to [ __ ]
help overthrow the government to
establish a [ __ ] fascist
a fascist regime having to do
uh to reinstate the [ __ ] uh to make
sure the united states would stay on the
damn gold
reserve and the uh these and the
newspapers denied that it ever happened
but it did happen
this that was another thing i'm [ __ ]
checking out it was just on this trip
this has been going on for a long time
so we done with this well you know there
was a couple other things that i
probably didn't uh
bring up but we've been going on for a
long time and is it time
you're you're kind of going off and i
can't i i feel like i can't really
i'm feeling good man go back into it you
can't go back into it i spoiled it
well because you're going off on like
all these other different directions
and you know okay you guys uh
i think i covered most of the [ __ ] at
least i got the timeline covered i got
all the victims in there i got
most of that kind of stuff but you know
um you know and like i said i went a
little bit into
how [ __ ] the coverage about it was
just because they wanted everything to
be
you know like i said they're just trying
to generate
not clicks back then but trying to
generate newspaper sales and
eyeballs on the tv so they're gonna make
everything as
scandalous salacious as possible so a
lot of [ __ ] was reported that
uh wasn't true but you know uh
that's we kind of covered that more or
less
we covered the marilyn manson angle
trying to think if there was anything
else that i wanted to bring up about
this
i mean there's a ton of like good stuff
about this i was watching some like
somebody asked me earlier
if i uh if i watched that
um uh that youtube show
caitlin dotty i think her name is uh ask
a mortician
she actually did a 15 minute uh video
about like debunking some of the
myths about the columbine massacre and
that's actually very good if you want to
check that out
also um there's this other guy i
subscribed to
what's his name dr todd grande and he's
a psychiatrist
and he will basically any true crime
case
any like crazy person that's in the
media
whether they killed somebody or not um
you know even like kanye west or
something like that
um he will give his insights into
uh what he thinks their [ __ ] problem
is and uh
because he's a psychiatrist he's been a
psychiatrist a long time and i love him
because
he's like so like nerdy and normal but
he has the best
[ __ ] driest sense of humor
that i have ever seen on anybody like he
will just totally
throw out like a joke but you totally
don't even realize it's a joke until
like three or four minutes late
like he's just like really really good
at doing that real dry like [ __ ]
shade
you know what i mean it's like it's
[ __ ] hilarious it's like i'll just be
like listen to him while i'm doing
something else and then like couple
minutes later and be like ah
[ __ ] okay i see what you did there uh
glowing turtle just jumps in
and asks why do school shootings happen
in the u.s
have you been listening to the show my
friend
the show explained why it happened well
there
no one knows exactly why but there's
like um
for sure there's a ton a ton of
different factors
been going on since the 1700s you can go
back to the 1600s
and there were kids who would get a big
old barrels of damn
black powder and try to blow up the damn
schoolhouse
with the kids in it there's always some
weird [ __ ] like that going on
it's just that it when it happened it
was always local news
so it never became a fad it never caught
on
you know as soon as you had national
news this
really started that that thing really
started when there was
cnn came about which was [ __ ] a
national news network
well it was 24 hours so they needed like
content
and they would sit there and just pump
the [ __ ] out over and over again and
they would make anything that would
anything that was shocking it'd make it
[ __ ] huge because well they knew that
people would watch it so in a lot of
ways
it's kind of like you can't blame the
media entirely because the media
wouldn't be doing it if people weren't
watching it
you know what i'm saying so if you just
stop watching the [ __ ]
or like i said if you don't like um you
know nowadays like news stories that are
all like outrage and it's like just
trying to get clicks don't click on it
you said if you didn't if you didn't
click on it
no one would you know they wouldn't do
it yeah
uh if you didn't watch it no one would
do it so
that's kind of why i try to not do that
kind of [ __ ]
turtle said he just showed up he's sorry
he didn't know yeah okay when i said
when i first started the [ __ ] show
i kind of threw that out of out there
that
this was not the first school shooting
um there was there were school shootings
that were happening back in the seven
some of them happened in the 70s and the
fbi
did a study on it and they
told the federal government
their recommendation was is to tell
the national news networks not to
[ __ ] cover that on a national level
that that could cause it to snowball
and for some reason the federal
government never told the news
not to take that to the national level
that
that that's what the fbi said should
have happened at least back in the 70s
from what i remember that's just off top
of my head well
well and honestly like i said people
like to blame the media nowadays but
this is something it's it's not just the
media it's humans
because even going back to the victorian
era back to the beginning of like
printed media
people love salacious
details and if a horrible crime happens
this happens it went back in the [ __ ]
jack the ripper case there was ones even
before that
um if you're gonna like print something
and
it's a choice between printing what
actually happened or printing something
that's
way more gruesome that you think is
gonna sell more papers
what do you think they're going to do
yeah so and like i said it's not
entirely the media's fault it's our
fault
because we buy the [ __ ] yeah we buy the
[ __ ]
yeah yeah we give them money for it so
that's why they do it they wouldn't do
it if you didn't give them money
when i was a kid growing up in school i
was in military academy
they taught us all about american
history and they were always saying like
oh yeah
back in the 20s and the 30s we had this
thing called
yellow journalism and they would tell us
all about how
they had these newspaper companies that
would just print fake news and fake news
about each other
just to sell copies of newspapers
and looking back on them you know they
never really did
say that yellow journalism stopped
because it didn't
it it it it's still yellow journey well
it's baked into
it's just the way that business works
well and like i said it's a business
that's catering to the people that are
buying their product
their product is a newspaper and if
more people buy the product when you
print horribly graphic
photographs or drawings back in the old
days of
really really graphic jack ripper
murders then that's what they will do
if they have to make [ __ ] up because
more people buy the paper then they will
do that as well
yeah that's all modern and modern
terminology would
would be fake news fake news fake news
in yellow journalism the same thing
even though they're but like i said it's
not new it's not
new it's same [ __ ] yellow journalism
and you know i love at least now
you know people [ __ ] about it now but
like i said back in the old days it was
a lot worse i feel like because you
didn't have a lot of
you know the average person didn't have
a lot of other options
you know if your newspaper yes i know
there were more newspapers in every city
because that was kind of like your only
source of information back then
but um you know if all the newspapers
decided they wanted to sell as many
copies as possible so we're just gonna
like
make up [ __ ] or you know print the most
salacious [ __ ] we can come up with
um you weren't really getting the best
information so at least nowadays
even though yes there's still a lot of
misinformation out there you can still
kind of get to the bottom of [ __ ] so
like i said you know in regards to the
columbine shooting
yes when this happened in 1999 the
narrative that happened after it
um a lot of the myths that sprung up
about it you know
blaming marilyn manson for example or
saying that oh they were bullied and
they were taking revenge you know almost
kind of like
not letting them off the hook for the
[ __ ] but at least kind of excusing it a
little bit
so i kind of feel like that was part of
the narrative that was sold but that's
because that's what people were buying
but
nowadays you can look up and see that
there's a lot of controversy about that
and people are
correcting things um you can you know
look at the actual
witness statements of people that were
there and um
see what they said and see how it
contradicts kind of the narrative that
the media ran with afterwards another
another [ __ ] incorrect
narrative that's being sold to the
american people is that the united
states is violent
it's not violent brazil is far more
violent
all right and they don't even they don't
legally they don't allow any
firearms there it's still far more
violent and they're saying that we are
that this is the most violent period in
history
[ __ ] [ __ ] crime
and violence in the 70s was a lot worse
60s was probably pretty bad too 80s was
bad
it's gotten a lot better um probably the
two most violent periods in [ __ ]
world history just in terms of
just violence and cruelty would have
been the european medieval era
yeah the [ __ ] late roman period
pretty [ __ ] violent just the damn
roman period itself is far more violent
the thing about nowadays you know yes
you could still
get murdered by a serial killer while
you're just walking around yes that
could still happen
but um you have to think that in the
modern era
at least most people
that you're gonna deal with have a
conception
that human life is valuable
whereas i feel like a lot of people
middle ages they didn't really you can't
take it for granted that they had that
mindset
no they did um for a long time people
didn't really have the mindset that
everyone's life was valuable that
everyone was valid
um life was very cheap yeah animals were
just play toys you could just [ __ ]
torture
exactly like no one thought anything
about that
they'd take a bunch of cats in the
medieval era and just tie their tails
together
put them in a big bundle and throw them
on the fire just watch it right if
somebody did that nowadays
you would be put in prison and
rightfully so stake a bear to the ground
just sit there and beat the bear to
death yeah and everybody be cheering
yeah they're [ __ ] you know i mean
people were [ __ ] psychos yeah and and
it
it wasn't just us too mesoamerica you
know [ __ ]
well everyone was kind of like that yeah
the aztecs and the mayans
you know for one second think that those
and the [ __ ] native americans those
weren't [ __ ] victims those people
were [ __ ] warriors
they were [ __ ] bad asses the [ __ ]
aztecs were [ __ ] they were the [ __ ]
man
they would just sacrifice people up on
temples you know for [ __ ]
religious purposes and stuff they killed
lots and lots of people they were
bloodthirsty
that's just the way humans were this is
where they just like that
and then you know all the native
american tribes they were bad asses too
they were [ __ ]
[ __ ] they'd [ __ ] they'd be okay you
gotta look you gotta put it this way
when it comes to the native americans
hollywood always shows the native
americans as some kind of
mopey ass victim oh my god these white
people shooting him up and it was
terrible
you got to look at this man the vikings
went in and whipped
every [ __ ] european kingdom's asses
consistently during the age of the
viking
they showed up to [ __ ] canada and met
native americans and got their asses
whipped
the vikings got their asses whipped by
the indians
okay indians were a warrior [ __ ]
people all right
they weren't weak they were very strong
and when they fought the
uh colonists british colonists american
colonists
the the american army they mostly lost
against the indians
the the whites like if you want to call
them whites you know
whites didn't start scoring any
victories against the indians until
after the damn railroads and cars and
when by that time indians were marrying
white people well that [ __ ]
had been going on for a long time it's
just tech
the technology and the changing
global situation thank you ken and did
the native american
way of life it was no longer possible
you just had them
farms everywhere and roads cars and you
just couldn't be an indian
the indian lifestyle was the [ __ ] man
you had a lot of white people joining up
with indian tribes marine indian people
women and men women white women would
run
and join the indians a lot of people
don't [ __ ] know like i said back in
those days i
can't blame you i probably would have
done white women were better off with
indians really that's what i'm saying
i probably and they would run off and
because that like they lived a very
healthy lifestyle in nature fresh water
fresh food they weren't [ __ ] living
in these damn stone ghettos out in new
york
[ __ ] with no electricity just gas
lamps and [ __ ]
bad sewage everywhere rotten food it's
just
plus they weren't allowed to do anything
we're not doing weird restrictions on
them and [ __ ]
yeah no man [ __ ] white man didn't
defeat the indians the indians were
defeated by the [ __ ] progress of the
they were defeated by the industrial
revolution
just changing time they weren't defeated
they just buried in white people
most most white people here including
jenny you know [ __ ] have a native
american in them you know just because
everybody got married i do my great
grandparents were
you know blackfoot india there weren't
enough white women so you know
white guys tried to [ __ ] marry women
whole indian women
[ __ ] there were whole tribes like the
mandan got
wiped out because they married white
people that's all
there wasn't any violence they just
married white people they just became
white people
so there's a lot of that going on and um
you know
don't believe what people say you gotta
[ __ ] look at the details in the
history well as i said everything's
always more complex
they have to teach you kind of you know
a thing about so you know something
about something but
everything is always if you want to take
a deep dive there's always
it's always more complex the first time
you if you go back in history the first
time i talk about this indian genocide
thing
it's racist white people trying to
[ __ ] say
that well the indians [ __ ] were
defeated
because of social darwinism we're a
superior race and that's not what
happened
you got your asses whipped no they don't
want to tell anybody they don't want to
say that
yeah nobody nobody likes to get their
bucket
but like i said i think the thing about
you know and i'm not saying that
you know crime's been bad you know
forever there's always this contingent
that's
you know that's going to commit crimes
and you know like i said serial killers
very bad in the 70s and 80s but you have
to think that going back to
as you said the roman era the medieval
era [ __ ] like that like before the
enlightenment let's say
um i do kind of feel like
no one would have really talked about it
it wouldn't have really been worth
talking about
because they didn't value individual
people's lives
or like you said animals lives
the way that we do now so as i said i
would never
ever go back to that time period because
the reason that people
talk about are fascinated by serial
killers now and are fascinated by crime
now
is because it's relatively rare yeah
um people just don't have the same
mentality that they had back then
where you know you could just kill
animals or you could kill people or
people died and it wasn't that
big a deal yeah i feel like it wasn't
that big a deal
amanda thought that the i said that the
indians went and defeated all the
vikings that's not what i said
man the [ __ ] stop that no when the
vikings came here no the vikings went to
canada
what was called newfoundland yeah they
were there for what
it's about 16. not all that long they
didn't have a huge settlement there
but they do know that they were there
because they found some of their they
couldn't handle the indians
they couldn't handle the indians they
had to go back to [ __ ]
yeah they couldn't colonize to a great
extent no they were
here because they found their artifacts
but they got along with the indians for
a little while but the indians thought
they poisoned them
because the uh the vikings were [ __ ]
they had
cows and they gave the indians some milk
and and they liked it but they threw it
up because they were lactose intolerant
which most people but the indians
thought that they had been poisoned so
they went and attacked them and [ __ ]
it started a big war
you know and eventually the event it was
eric the red i think is what his name
was
i think i think it was named the guy who
founded that calling i think was eric
the red
yeah what was that okay either the red
or leaf eriksson one of the two
and uh they said [ __ ] it and they packed
up and left it's like you guys poisoned
us
but they did vikings were stupid i mean
they were smart but they were stupid at
the same time and when they saw somebody
they didn't
they didn't recognize the race they'd
kill them to see if they were immortal
that's some crazy [ __ ] well what the so
they made enemies wherever they went
oh i guess they were kill that thing see
if it dies
oh well it's mortal okay it's living
burn
yeah just kind of like that thing where
it's like let's see if this woman's a
witch they throw her in the river
guess she wasn't a witch oh well well
they showed up [ __ ] they showed up in
america see what i'm saying about
life being cheap yeah i'd say look at
that scrambling kill it kill it and see
if it's real
yeah it it's it's mortal huh why are
they attacking us
[Laughter]
that's pretty funny when you think about
it from that point but like you said
that's how they would have thought of it
because they don't really think of
they wouldn't really think of you as
like another human they were a human
no well of course not because that's
just so funny to me
in a horrible [ __ ] up way well you
have to understand that [ __ ]
um odin made vikings
he odin made the norsemen he didn't make
any of the other
people he just made norsemen yeah like
every religion every year says that
exact same thing
so all their people by other gods and
don't worship them
so you know that's that's y'all are
different y'all are made for a different
god
yeah so that's what they're talking
about that's [ __ ] hilarious
it makes perfect i mean like i said it's
[ __ ] up but it's hilarious yeah
that they would think that well it's
kind of like that in genesis though
well well no that's what i just said
every religion is like that adam and eve
is kind of like the
where special god damn it they're the
first two people but then they get
kicked out of the garden and they're
they're afraid of being hurt by the
other people well who are the other
people
yeah it's like
the first two jews yeah okay
there was other people other people they
just weren't like
people people right it's the same thing
as the vikings that's what i'm saying
it's like every religion has
that yeah well that's in a way you could
argue that that's the whole function of
religion
to make certain people just feel like
they're special and everyone else is
well if you're in a little tribe that's
what you feel like right yeah
it's worthy of who are these other
[ __ ] let's kill them
yeah yeah we need to wipe them out
they're not like us
they're living in a small little tribe
yeah so that's that's
that's the story of a small tribe and
like i said that's
kind of it's kind of hard to beat that
out of like humans because they
have that i mean you know it's a human
nature just way there
it is you have to accept things for how
they are and people for how they are
well you do but on the other hand you
can't just like accept people acting
just whatever way and act it takes time
it does it takes a long time but people
seriously it's been a long time get your
[ __ ] together
i'm just saying that right now growth is
never linear
no it's not and you have to understand
two steps forward one step back
yeah and you know there's there's
there's evolutionary factors and genetic
factors and
things you know what i mean there's a
lot of people that no longer exist
because they couldn't adapt
but as i said so from that i mean
as i said i'm really into i've always
been really into like you know
evolutionary science like evolutionary
biology
so as impatient as i am
i'm willing to understand that yeah this
is a long game
and you have to kind of like look back
it's like and so i kind of
feel like as shitty as things are on
whatever given day or whatever given
time period they live in look back
a couple hundred years look back you
know 600 years 700 years
um would you want to live back then no
no
oh that depends then no i would not
i could go to the back to the roman era
but i don't have you go i'm not
i would have been i'm not going i would
have to be a free man though
i'm a girl and i would want to be a
roman citizen
i would not want to be a a foreigner a
german or a [ __ ]
helvetii or any or anything like that
because this [ __ ] just grab you and
enslave you
you know what i mean but i would love to
see rome
i'd like to go see those games you know
i'd carry a [ __ ] some penicillin with
me though
penicillin that's what i'm saying
there's a whole bunch of people i mean
it just wouldn't be
and
this wouldn't be worth it to me because
you know those you know they're
dangerous over there
you know you know you know it's just the
food
the food would be bad i saw what they
they i saw the rest of that that's what
i'm saying
to me it seems like it would be cool to
kind of if you could make a time machine
that you could like watch the [ __ ] like
you were like watching an aquarium
yeah you know what i mean um and be like
oh that's interesting like watch it like
you
were watching like a museum diorama
actually living back then [ __ ]
that no thank you and like i said
especially
it would be like 100 times worse for me
because i'm a woman so i'm really really
not going back to like any [ __ ]
unenlightened [ __ ] back then for real
i don't even want to go back to like the
early 20th century i wouldn't even go
back to the 50s
[ __ ] going back to the [ __ ] ancient
or medieval times
no way tila says you can't try you can't
taste the difference between almond milk
based ice cream
because it's good i don't think i've
ever had like we drink almond milk
pretty much exclusively i don't even
think we have any real milk anymore
almond milk is good on cereal too but i
don't think i've ever had uh ice cream
made with almond milk i've drunk
like um you know starbucks makes those
coffee drinks that are made with almond
milk those are good
but i don't think i've ever had the ice
cream made with it
you know what i'm saying but yeah so in
case you're ever feel
you know if if you ever kind of wake up
and you feel like man like the [ __ ]
world is going to [ __ ] and everything
like that
it's getting better it is um it it
doesn't seem like it some days i get
that
but i don't know every time this memory
is like really vivid for me i don't know
why but i was like at my grandmother's
house and these two like old bats like
showed up at her
door and she wasn't home so i had to
answer it
and these two old bats are just kind of
like they were they weren't jehovah's
witnesses what's this what's those other
people that are always like a costume
people they weren't mormons
but they were i don't know they were
just from some [ __ ] church that had
just opened nearby
and their first their opening pitch
was isn't it sad like how terrible like
the world is going these days like this
war and that thing
and that and then like i'm looking at
them going it's gotten better
and that's different to any other time
in history huh
no actually no it's gonna and yeah and
i'm just like and that's
even the wars have less casualties in
them than they used to compare to the
[ __ ] first and the second world war
it's just uh it's just a different time
yeah you're going to see a lot of [ __ ]
fall apart but it will be rebuilt
that's another that's what i mean it's
like things are falling apart is because
they're obsolete they're too old
or they're just too corrupt that's why
i'm not bothered about it it happens
it's part of the cycle
it's not it's not negative to me it's
not bumming me out it's just kind of
like well
you know it's sad because you know
change is always scary for people but
it's like if that was something that had
outlived its usefulness
right you know as i said like the way
[ __ ] is going nowadays this is the way
that i always hoped that it would go
i'm like holy [ __ ] what will result is
more freedom
that's what will result well it's like
the if i can just like if everyone could
just leave me alone and i could just
make [ __ ] in my house
yeah and not starve to death then
whatever right usually what ends up
happening
in a civilization as it starts to age
and age out
is that its institutions start [ __ ]
becoming obsolete and they start running
into debt
so what they start to do is they start
to lower their standards to try to bring
up revenue
and when they do that they lose the very
nature that they had
so therefore the value declines even
further
here's an example you have a foot you
have a university
you try to keep a staff full of damn
students
but the students aren't coming like they
used to come because
you can now get an education for cheaper
elsewhere
or you don't people don't need the
education that the
university is selling so what do you do
you change the curriculum
to allow more people to come into the
college all right
you make it easier in other words you're
kind of dumbing it down
but when you do that it's no longer the
college it was so its reputation starts
declining
so it's an endless cycle and what you
end up having and the reason why they're
doing this is they're doing this because
they have to pay the debt
that they had so the university becomes
more
scam-like than it was an institution of
education
you're seeing that right now in the
entire university system
they said i think they said there was
going to be 500 of them closing
over the next two years and it's because
one college degrees aren't in great
demand in a lot of places
they're just not all right not everybody
needs them
the other other thing uh reason why it's
happening is because you can get a
really good education
online for a short amount of money
three the jobs aren't really there most
people are working from home
and a lot of them are running their own
business why would you work for these
corporations
they're just going to outsource your job
anyway so everyone's be
becoming kind of like jenny and me we
work from home
thank you kendall thank you we love you
guys i listen to y'all at work makes the
night bearable oh
that's nice the biggest recording artist
right now is tom mcdonald
and he's doing just what me and jenny
are doing he does all the rapping and
writing it writing and his wife
[ __ ] edits the videos that [ __ ] is
making millions of dollars
millions with no manager no record label
nothing so where are all these scam
artists how where
how are they going to survive they're
not going to
it's going to fall apart but that's good
it's not bad it's good
that's progress well like i said this is
why i never get like
super upset about stuff because people
who are
creator who can create things that other
people want to
consume if you want to use that word um
you know if you can write cool stories
or you can make cool movies or you can
you know make cool games or like [ __ ]
that people want to
buy or will pay for then you can just do
that and you can just put it up and
people
who like your [ __ ] can just have access
to it and there's not a big rigmarole
about it
yeah you know what i mean yeah so people
are like well what about all the workers
what's gonna happen to them
you're gonna be replaced by robots how
are they how are they going to survive
they're probably going to give you a ubi
i don't have a problem with that
honestly mexico has ubi
he got some [ __ ] if you go to college
you get ubi next that's probably what
will happen
well a lot of countries have that and
you um i don't think that's a bad idea i
think
well because i think that people should
have at least a baseline
well here's the thing you should have
enough it to at least have a room to
stay in enough food to eat
so you don't starve here's the thing at
least
automation robots and ai were supposed
to free
human beings from drudgery and toil and
that's what it's doing
but who who benefits these corporations
well how are you going to afford the
product these corporations are making
these corporations have to somehow give
money to the government
or through a system to make sure that
you have a universal basic income
to buy the products that these
corporations are making so
the corporations are going to fund it
because they
money isn't something that just appears
and vanishes it's a circulatory system
like blood
just because they give you something
doesn't mean it vanishes they're going
to get it right back
well you have to put it back into the
system you give
money you know it you know if if people
get
you know a a check you know from you
know the
the coven 19 thing or whatever um you
know
i don't know about you guys but i need i
have bills to pay so that's gonna go
back into the economy i have [ __ ] i need
to buy i gotta buy shampoo
i gotta like [ __ ] pay my car
insurance i gotta do [ __ ] like that
so it's gonna go back into the economy
so yeah
in that way it's kind of better to give
money to just regular ass people like me
because we're gonna spend it because we
kind of have to you're basically talking
about something kind of like a star trek
yeah we're basically growing technology
is causing
us to grow out of economy
in a way our economy based upon
traditional financial concepts
now the marxist concepts of [ __ ]
capitalism and [ __ ] communism and
socialism
those are long obsolete now because what
we're dealing with now is more like
that's steampunk [ __ ] from the 1800s
what we're dealing with is [ __ ] way
above that this is fusion
this is making money out of nothing
there is no gold standard
this is just this is far above what
anything marx could have imagined
mark's thought wealth was just a pie
like a pie
you sliced it and you you divided it up
and you well in that day it was there
was only
so much wealth that you know yeah gold
standard and
it was something that could be
represented it was land
or it was gold or something like that
it's not anymore
but he couldn't have envisioned that
yeah what's happening now is we're in a
situation where you got the pie
why divide the pie because you can make
unlimited pie
it's very different i can make you want
a [ __ ] pie there's a [ __ ] pot
and that's what's going to happen it's
just that has to be done right
they have to do it in a way that that it
acts as like a circulatory system
which is kind of vaguely kind of shown
in star trek
yeah i mean as long as you know as i
said people can create things
right and you know other people can find
things
and there's an economy and it's just
like you know no one's like a
billionaire or anything like that but
everyone
is okay um
well there's got to be billionaires
because the government is owned by those
billionaires
without the billionaires the government
vanishes for now
it will always be like that um what
you're
you're going to have is you're going to
have oligarchs and they're they far
outperform
um they far out perform governments
like uh what spacex can do
nasa can never do i mean they're just
they're already [ __ ] building [ __ ]
spaceships
and starships at an amazing [ __ ] rate
and because there's no bureaucracy
government bureaucracy is always
and here's another thing is that
government will always be filled with
inept people they're just totally inept
and totally unqualified for leadership
they couldn't lead me across the [ __ ]
street all right
they will never be any good quality
people in the government worked for it
um so never put your
faith in them they're not trying to help
you they hate you
it's it's gonna be a mixture of a bunch
of stuff it'll be an
entirely new network no
no this is what would happen
if you had an all-powerful government
like that eventually you'd have a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like me in charge of it
that's what would happen no one wants
yeah you want that
i'm telling you right now you don't want
that you do not want anything
centralized no
nothing top down you want a network that
works
where everything's democratized
are you done okay i can never tell
yeah um so we've wandered kind of far
afield from the columbine massacre but
like i said i was
mostly done talking about that we kind
of got into all the stuff that i wanted
to
every time you wanted all the stuff that
we covered we covered pretty much all
the important stuff right yeah
everybody knows thomas is having good
just having fun
i wonder how long we've been on we've
been doing probably for a million hours
no
um this is the third part yeah
the third part we're now at uh one hour
and 14
minutes so i i can't remember i think
the first part was an hour and then the
second part was two hours and something
yeah so we're probably at more than four
hours at this point
um so do you want to like wrap it up or
yeah yeah all right
it's hot as hell man are you having your
like hormonal issues again
you having your hot flashes your
menopause aren't you
no it's not menopause you're talking
about this man react man
reenact reinactivation talking about
like a phoenix rising from the ashes
amanda said you start at 3 p.m my time
uh at our time what is it
it's 8 39 p.m i think is it or no
that that no it's 10 31 pm
my computer crashed over here and the
clock apparently crashed as well two
hours ago
and i didn't notice so i didn't realize
it was 10 30 already holy [ __ ]
but it's friday night i can sleep in
tomorrow
yeah you know caramel says free hookers
and blow
well you know that's that's everyone's
goal you're asking that i should be
president tom for dictator
well let let me know when that's going
to happen so i can move
away
saying i'm much more positive this day
he is actually
um you know it comes and goes but
i'm in a transitional period he was
getting a point where he just thought
everything sucked and it was like and i
was just like man i can't deal with this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna move i was thinking about
it i gotta say man i can't
well the thing about it is that like i'm
not like this big like [ __ ] pollyanna
optimus person
but i don't really i don't really like
i enjoy a lot of things i find a lot of
joy in my life and i can't really
be around somebody that's just like
[ __ ] on everything all the time
and i kind of feel like she character
you were kind of like that
everything all the time but no that's
kind of yeah that's what you were doing
though all right so it's like everything
and then
like this i don't like this either i
don't like this i'm just kind of like
man
you don't like anything that's what
you're like all right good
that's what being around you was like so
i was just kind of like man this is like
bumming me out yeah all right
i can't be around somebody like that so
you know
kieran says smile tomorrow can get worse
yeah don't say that oh well
you're all right yeah i'm done i can't
believe
that it's 10 30. i was looking at this
thinking it was like well i was thinking
it was like really early because i was
looking at this computer but like i said
this computer crashed
yeah apparently two hours ago and i
didn't notice
yeah yeah it was two hours ago so i'm
saying this [ __ ] yeah i'm
saying we're done show's done okay like
i said i think i covered everything
i mean there's tons of other [ __ ] but i
couldn't get into all of it obviously i
over
you got the main part of it though i
took so many like copious notes like i
always do because i always try to like
no no you made it almost down the bottom
no well i
scrolled down okay other than that you
know what i mean i was just kind of
scrolling through here it's like is
there anything else important here that
i
well we can always revisit really wanted
to mention and then like i forgot
to it's like you know yeah there was a
lot left but whatever
um some of this was kind of like
aftermath kind of [ __ ]
and some of this was [ __ ] that we kind
of like mentioned just yeah offhand
talked about it anyway but you know so
it's it's not as bad as it looks
okay i guess because i was i always like
over research
i noticed that well i have to it's the
way you are
because damn
look at this [ __ ] you gotta give your
own camera man
you gotta get off
me get off the camera go find pokey yeah
all right out on the backyard anyway
yeah go find her i think she's sitting
by the tree in the backyard all right so
uh anyway have a good rest of your
weekend you guys we'll see you guys
again on sunday we're gonna do a matinee
review we're actually gonna be covering
uh the movie wind river which louie sent
to us uh which we watched last night
which is actually really good
kind of a thriller based on our true
story so we're gonna be talking about
that on sunday
and uh as always thanks everybody for
dropping by and hanging out with us
on friday night drinking with us talking
about this horrific [ __ ]
uh remember like share subscribe on all
your social media if you'd like to
financially support the show and go to
our
patreon page patreon.com 13 o'clock
podcast
or if you'd like to give a one-time
donation it would also be much
appreciated you go to our blog
13 o'clock podcast.wordpress.com
o'clockpodcast.wordpress.com there's a
button in the sidebar that goes to a
paypal account
again if you'd like to give a one-time
donation if you don't want to do patreon
because i know some people don't like
that
and uh so we will see you guys on sunday
have a great weekend until then we'll
see you then
bye